wow oh yeah did you see this wow what's
crazy is we was I swear to y'all my son
I was just in the car before I got here
talking about Tupac and Makaveli because
I was like y'all know people I ain't
saying he did but I was like y'all know
people really do fake their deaths and
stuff like to get away from Fame because
I can understand that because Fame it's
like
yeah I was I think of death too to get
away from this yeah
it'd be a lot it'd be a lot because it's
just a byproduct of success a lot of
times especially in this day and age you
know where everything's so visible but
yeah they said that this guy I think
he'd been going on podcast what was his
name what did he say kef d
he's long been known to investigators as
one of four suspects identified early in
the investigation he isn't the accused
gunman what was described as the group's
ringleader
um they just now locked him up he was in
the car Davis himself has admitted in
interviews and in his 2019 tell all
Memoir Compton can you scroll
so that's what I got is dumbass Compton
Street legend that he provided the gun
used in a drive-by wow he's so dumb hey
when are these years without getting
caught you're gonna go on there on the
interview thinking she cool to talk
about but do you think because you're
crazy he might be do you think though
that he did it because does it say that
he's dying
he had cancer back in the day he had
cancer
[Music]
but he was gonna have to on his deathbed
type yeah he thought he was dying
of cancer so that's why I think he
started to talk more about it that's
crazy and they didn't came a lot but now
he's still alive and in jail now
that's crazy that's crazy
um what do you think about that what
were you guys talking about it when you
talked about it we were just saying like
because people used to be trying to act
like they spotted Tupac here in there
yeah oh they said Elvis didn't really
die yeah people say he's here and there
people seen him at Dollar General do you
I think stuff like that could be real we
just never know like anything is
possible to me oh yeah I wouldn't be
surprised maybe if you had enough if you
had enough money and enough Connections
in the media you could make it happen
like um what was that rapist was this
not Epstein yeah they were saying he not
dead for real remember they said
somebody killed him and himself yeah
they said the cameras were off the
guards weren't there and he died he hung
himself
I don't know people were saying he not
really did he just got all that money
and he got he probably somewhere living
life on the other side of the world
right now and he looks like the kind of
creep that they would let loose in this
yeah in this world
man when money talk that's one thing
about it so I don't know I believe it's
possible that people can affect their
deaths and just gone about their way
yeah that's possible but you if somebody
sees that guy though it's going to be a
wrap but you know they could change
their face it's things like that now
really
people probably yeah they get surgeries
and all that change how they look change
their identity when you got money yeah
you can do whatever you want to do yeah
because see let me get some money and
commit a crime and let me have a lot of
money like a billionaire and I need to
do this to do that baby I'm a new I'm
not even that person I would I don't
know what kind of what surgery would you
get you think to hide
um probably like a face reconstruction
breast reduction too really he might
have no yes to change everything like
you better show up yeah thinking like
she had big titties if people see them
cups they might know what she is you
know they see them red Solo cups baby
yeah I think uh I would get them maybe a
longer neck
and people be like is that him and
they're like no that won't make a
difference he will he got that long ass
yeah look at right there hey she coming
up dang suddenly she's a good swimmer
the internet
I said okay swim you think they're gonna
make me float yeah girl yeah that's
funny or start a job as a fairy the
internet and I'll buy a ticket
come on internet is crazy isn't it hope
you enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one